[Music]
this is 96.5
bolton fm
boris johnson has resigned as prime
minister after less than three years in
office
it was constituencies like bolton north
east in greater manchester that got
boris johnson into power
part of the so-called labour red wall
that in 2019
turned blue when you come to a
constituency like this one which turned
conservative for the first time in
decades back in 2019 and you ask people
why did you vote conservative you'll
often hear three things first that they
believed what the conservative party was
saying about brexit then about leveling
up but really it's because people say
they light boris johnson
and that inspired some people to vote
conservative for the very first time
hello like ann griffiths who lives at a
very different number 10 with her
bulldog winston
he was a big character and he said what
he felt sometimes it was wrong maybe it
wasn't politically correct who gives a
damn i still think he cares passionately
about england and wales and scotland and
northern ireland and do you believe
there is anyone else within the
conservative party that would persuade
you to vote for the party again no
quite simply no and the reason i have
fought so hard in the last few days
and the loss of those votes could be
significant the tory mp here won in 2019
by the slimmest of margins his
supporters fear he wouldn't win again
i'm very disappointed because um i think
the red ball
uh
constituencies are just going to go back
to being labor
because uh boris brought the red world
down and he got he got their attention
and they wanted him working class people
actually wanted to vlog 170 for the
first time
i think that's lost now
how did you feel seeing the resignation
speech today it was a bit sweet moment i
think people have expected it for a long
time
will bruce has always voted labour but
today for him it didn't feel like a day
to celebrate i think he needs to go now
i think for me to
actually have a cha a real change of
leadership
so that basically we can actually kind
of deal with the issues of the country
that have been like with inflation and
fuel crisis especially in a poor working
class town like bolton this is a place
with many social challenges for some the
prime minister's resignation feels like
a relief
since the prime minister was found to a
breach the rules he set up himself i
think he should have gone really i don't
know why they kept him there he was just
a lame dog
more or less really it's a bit of hope
now that somebody else could be there
that we have a new team that is going to
give people hope and more confidence for
the conservative party the pressure is
now on to find a leader who can make
sure that votes lent in 2019
return next time
catcher of autopsy sky news in bolton